the wind and the Sun
a version of the tale by the
fablecottage.com
the wind and the sun are having a
disagreement
I am the most powerful says the wind no
I am the most powerful says the Sun
I can blow trees to the ground brags the
wind I can push ships across the ocean
I can make hurricanes and tornadoes
is that right replies the sun well I can
melt all the snow on the mountains
I can dry up an entire Lake
I can make a pavement so hot that it
Cooks an egg
just then they see a man walking along
the road in his winter jacket
let's have a contest to see who is more
powerful says the wind
whoever can remove the man's jacket
first wins
the sun agrees
the wind goes first
he blows a gust of cold wind at the man
the man Shivers and zips up his jacket
what a cold and windy day
it starts to rain
the wind blows even harder and turns the
rain into snow
well look at that it's snowing says the
man
snow wasn't in the weather forecast
today
he pulls his hood over his head
the wind blows his strongest gust
towards the man but the man's jacket
stays on
hmm it's a bit fresh today he says a
winter storm must be coming
he Zips the jacket higher to cover his
nose
[Music]
this is impossible says the wind he
stops blowing
my turn says the Sun
first The Sun Shines enough to stop the
snow
the man unzips his hood
then the sun pulls the clouds apart and
gently shines down on the man
suddenly it is a beautiful spring day
wow the weather sure is strange around
here says the man
he unzips his jacket
the sun gently Wiggles her fingers and
increases the temperature
strange weather now it feels like summer
the man says as he begins to sweat
goodness me it's so hot
he removes his winter jacket he lies
down on the grass for a nap in the warm
sun
I win says the sun beaming
moral
sometimes warmth and gentleness can
achieve more than strength and force